metz ville ancienne possède un caractère
tout à fait particulier passé romain de
l'ancien divodurum évêché célèbre
jusqu'au xiiie siècle et la ville libre
avec à sa tête un mètre et chemins vie
le fier qui a ses monuments ses
particularités et qui a su souffrir dans
cette cité et les rues possède des noms
tout à fait particulier un historien
local andré jean maire a écrit un
ouvrage intitulé dans les rues du vieux
metz j'ai toujours été attiré par les
vieilles choses par les vieux objets et
par les vieilles maisons depuis quelques
temps mais subit des bouleversements
extrêmement important des quartiers
entiers sont appelés à disparaître et il
est intéressant de pouvoir au moins
gardé le souvenir de certaines choses de
ces quartiers de certains vieux
monuments de certaines vieilles portes
de certains vieux hôtels même qu'ils
sont voués à la démolition c'est
prochaine certains quartiers de metz
d'ailleurs sont déjà complètement rasé
la leur physionomie et changer
complètement et certains articles de ce
livre sont déjà dépassés et bien
maintenant si vous le voulez nous allons
nous promener ensemble dans ses vieilles
rues louis quelle est cette rude
typiquement moyenâgeuse
c'est la rue de la bo elle a en effet
conservé un caractère absolument
moyenâgeux on n'a pas pu la grandir on
n'a pas pu la transformer et son nom
vient
d'un ancien mot patois mais saint lô qui
voulait dire fausse parce que vous savez
qu'au moyen-âge
même dans les villes les églises étaient
en général entourée d'un cimetière
eh bien monsieur aujourd'hui nous nous
trouvons nos vrais bien nous trouvons
comme vous l'avez vu au fond d'une cour
de la rue fourni rue devant un vieil
hôtel un vieil hôtel qui a été construit
par un orfèvre à l'époque de françois
1er
vous avez d'ailleurs une date au fond
vous verrez tout à l'heure qui voit un
écusson qui porte la date de 15 129 ce
qu'il ya de particulier c'est surtout ce
bas relief qui est assez curieux qui
représente un combat de sauvage contre
des lions nous trouvons là devant une
vieille maison assez curieuse
oui hélas ceci d'intéressant que l a été
habité au début du 16e siècle par le
célèbre peintre verrier valentin bush
qui a fait la célèbre verrière de la
cathédrale de metz
les bêtes immo quel est il c'est un
bâtiment qui date du 14ème siècle et qui
est un ancien grenier au moyen-âge à
metz on entreposait énormément de grains
et il existait beaucoup de ces greniers
dont deux subsiste encore pendant la
révolution on y entreposer des armes et
notamment des bics et se fait à donner à
la rue le nom de rue des piles qu avant
cette petite rue s'appelait rue de la
fleur de lys du nom d'une ancienne
galerie que nous verrons qui s'appelait
maison de la fleur de lys maintenant je
ne sais pas si c'est la rue qui a donné
son nom à l'hôtellerie au contraire qui
s'est produit
monsieur le maire vous pouvez vous nous
dire sur ce petit mot il abrite
actuellement le conservatoire de musique
et il est considéré comme le plus ancien
spécimens d'architecturé
six villes de metz il date en effet du
moins une partie d' acte du 12e siècle
et la partie supérieure avec la tour une
tour qui a sept étages date du xiiie
siècle
maintenant les gens s'attachent beaucoup
à leur passé plus peut-être qu'à voir un
plus peut-être plus qu'avant oui
effectivement le goût du public revient
beaucoup à l'ancien aux meubles de style
c'est peut-être en contrepartie de la
vie et que nous menons actuellement de
la vie trépidante de la vie un petit peu
nerveuse que nous menons est alors
arrêté son regard sur un vieux meuble
sur un vieil objet ou créer créer chez
soi une ambiance un peu anciennes repose
énormément